Hi, I'm Brett, a Software Engineer on the App Engine team.
In this screen cast, we'll purchase additional resources
for an application running on Google App Engine.
In the Admin Console, there are new links for Billing--
a settings page and a history page.
Let's go to the settings page and enable billing for this app.
I click Enable Billing and that takes me to the Setup page.
I set a max daily budget,
choose either a budget preset or a custom budget.
The custom option allows me to tune each resource if I know what usage to expect.
I set my country
review my Checkout authorized weekly charge limit and click Checkout.
I go through the Checkout process and return to the Billing settings page.
After my credit card is authorized, my Resource Allocations will be updated in a few minutes.
On the Dashboard, you can see the resources I've purchased.
It will also tell me how much I've spent today for each resource.
The marker indicates where the free quotas are, which still apply.
Later, if I want to increase or decrease my budget, I can quickly reallocate my daily quota.
The Billing History page is like a bank statement.
It lists all billing events and how they affect the app's budget and running balance.
For convenience, we have a print function that makes it easier to submit these for expense reporting.
Thanks for watching.